wir haben jetzt jungs gerade erlebt mit
der umsetzung des
bundesverkehrswegeplans zur
zum weiterbau der a100 hier in der
hauptstadt in berlin großen widerstand
der grünen die auf der einen seite das
im deutschen bundestag mitgetragen habe
auf der anderen seite in berlin kein
meter dieser autobahn wollen wer die
zukunft gestalten will der braucht eine
funktionierende verkehrsinfrastruktur
denn wasserstoff antriebe und
elektroantriebe brauchen genau das auch
und darüber hinaus auch heute die
diskussion um die frage der ukraine und
die
versorgungsengpässe die uns bevorstehen
möglicherweise fordern uns gerade wenn
es um trassen bauten geht wie den
südlichen deshalb mein dringender appell
mehr pragmatismus um die großprojekte in
deutschland voranzubringen denn es ist
dringender denn je hertha hat er recht
aber ehrlich gesagt ja ich kann es nicht
mehr hören weil das sagen wir jetzt seit
20 jahren das haben wir gesagt als ich
regierungssprecher der rot grünen
bundesregierung war es gibt immer wieder
irgend jemand der sich um
bürokratieabbau kümmert irgendjemand der
sachen schneller machen wollen ich saß
im transrapid in shanghai als der eine
technologie die wir abgeschafft haben
schnurgerade innerhalb von wenigen
minuten vom flughafen dann innenstadt
rollt und das ist ja genau das problem
wir wir entwickeln unsere technik nicht
weiter wir exportieren sie dort wird sie
umgesetzt mit maßnahmen die wir gar
nicht wollen auch nicht ich meine wir
wollen auf der einen seite schnelligkeit
beim bauen wie in china auf der anderen
seite wollen wir aber immer mehr
bürgerbeteiligung bürgerfreiheit dafür
stehen sie auch tolle sache nur wie
passt das zusammen wir erleben wenn es
jetzt inventar von den box oder woody
allen die termin ist gebaut werden
sollen das kleinst tiere nicht
kleintiere sondern kleinst tiere
wahrscheinlich mikroskopisch große
diesem baum möglicherweise behindern
werden weil der bund für naturschutz
sagt da ist irgendwas im bad das muss
man aber schützen jedes lebewesen hat
schutz verdient absolut bin ich auch für
nur diese dualität und sich dann hin zu
stellen so zu sagen ja wir brauchen ein
bisschen mehr schnelligkeit das ist
wichtig das ist sehr wohlfeil ich mir
übrigens doch mal zu ihrem autobahn
projekt das auch sehr ungewöhnlich
zumindest das verfahren das ich gelesen
habe denn das war offenkundig nicht vom
minister mit der landesregierung
abgestimmt oder abgesprochen die auch
bundesverkehrswegeplan dann hätten wir
aus seiner lesen können es richtig
normalerweise redet miteinander ich
finde das ist eine debatte die ich will
gar nicht führen aber es ist recht
wohlfeil sich hinzustellen und zu sagen
wir brauchen mehr schnelligkeit dann
muss man auch sagen wie funktioniert das
mit der bürgerbeteiligung gibt es die
wie im bisherigen maße oder gibt es sie
nicht und muss man da auch was schneller
machen das ist ja offenkundig auch dass
sie unter anderem von robert habe ich
glaube dass bevor wir über die frage der
bürgerbeteiligung reden und glauben dass
da gebremst wird was auch wir gerade
beim südlichen thüringer erleben dass
viele bürgerinitiativen sich dagegen
stellen auf der anderen seite aber sagen
wir müssen dringend in erneuerbare
energien investieren aber bitte nicht
vor meiner haustür die entsprechenden
baumaßnahmen dass wir uns dessen mal
bewusst werden müssen in unserem land
dass wenn wir uns den herausforderungen
der zukunft stellen wollen dass es für
jeden vielleicht auch persönliche
einschnitte mitbringt gerade wenn es um
solche baumaßnahmen geht temporär und
ich glaube nicht dass wir vom durch das
bautempo bestimmen lassen sollten
sondern an dieser stelle ganz klar auch
für den fortschritt und das was an
notwendigkeit ist eintreten und das ist
auch so daher gesagt jetzt ja weil
ehrlich gesagt wenn sie auf dem land
leben machen wir doch mal konkret sie
leben auf dem land zu ziehen ausland
raus aus berlin haben die idylle dort
auf einmal kommt der südlich oder der
nord link eine riesen trasse vor ihrer
tür oder jemand sagt ich brauche ihnen
windkraftanlagen wo keine stehen sollte
die nachts immer schön rum achtner sagen
sie dann toll für die allgemeinheit
finde ich das gut oder versuchen sie
nicht vielleicht auch zu sehen dass
diese trasse paar kilometer weiter nach
süden oder nach osten oder nach westen
verschoben wird und sagen diese
windkraftanlage die sache anders sehen
also da ist nicht glaube ich immer noch
jeder selbst der nächste kommen sagen
leider aber so ist es im moment und da
finde ich es einfacher es ist so wie mit
dem gürtel enger schlagen ja jeder muss
irgendwas tun aber aber sie bieten auch
keine lösung da ich sage es muss daher
ein gewinner barbara dürfen sie jetzt
kommt die passage oper erzählt vom krieg
am montag haben die sich noch früher
erinnern können wir hatten von 1991 das
muss doch einander wissen wir hatten von
1990 bis 2006 auch lamers oft erst wege
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
wir haben alle gewusst der gesetzgeber
hat manchmal helle momente haben alle
gewusst mit dem planungsrecht west
bekommen wie die neuen bundesländer in
den nächsten jahrzehnten in der
infrastruktur nicht aufforderung an dass
alle gewusst deswegen hat ist nur für
die neuen länder und berlin dieses
verkehrswege
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz gegeben
was überhaupt nur zwölf paragrafen hatte
und nur eine einzige instanz wenn
geklagt wurde kein instanzen zug soll
erste und letzte instanz waren das
bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig man
hätte ihr auf die idee kommen können
dieses recht auf die ganze
bundesrepublik deutschland zu übertragen
also ich bin also 99 prozent auf der
seite von herrn dreyer aber ich muss
auch er an einem punkt recht geben
sobald es um beschleunigung geht kommt
sofort die nächste frage werden hier
nicht bürger beteiligungsrechte abgebaut
ja da muss man sich entscheiden
es schneller und mehr bürgerbeteiligung
wird nicht gehen schneller und mehr
umwelt und naturschutz wird nicht gehen
und der andere hat zu recht darauf
hingewiesen wie das bei uns in
deutschland läuft in der sache selber
hat der scharia recht ist muss schneller
wird
aber diese zeit fordert uns doch
insbesondere wir können doch nicht über
die frage nachdenken wie können wir
erneuerbare energien in unserem land
schneller aufbauen und fokussieren und
auf der anderen seite schaffen wir nicht
die entsprechenden voraussetzungen dafür
zu schaffen und das ist mein appell dass
es uns alle fordern wird und das bringt
uns vielleicht zum will die moderation
nicht übernehmen
mit dem feld
von wladimir klitschko gehört haben dass
es uns eben alle betrifft und uns
betrifft es hier ziemlich direkt in
diesen fragen die wir jetzt auch angeben
der ausgang der sendung ist noch nicht
ganz da er sei also habe ich noch zeit
ihn ein die rückfrage zu stellen und
diese rückfrage ist ja wir wollen es
schneller machen und auch bo kratie
natürlich abbauen aber ist die
bürokratie nicht vielleicht auch ein
zeichen einer gesunden demokratie man
kennt das von autoritären staaten wo
schnell auch form umgesetzt werden
können ist es nicht vielleicht auch mit
bürokratie auch auf den geist aber kann
es sich auch im zeichen einer gesunden
demokratie sein der sänger dauert es
kommt auf die geschwindigkeit an in der
tat aber ich brauche nicht jeden
verwaltungsakt dreimal
in der bosbach hatten hervorragende idee
hier eingeschlagen das gesetz ja
beschleunigungsgesetz und das ist das
ist im grunde die art und weise wie man
mit diesen herausforderungen umgehen
kann bei es hat ja auch zu guten
ergebnissen geführt weitestgehend
sicherlich seit 91 und vielleicht ist
jetzt die zeit dass wieder anzusetzen
zeit für ein beschleunigungsgesetz in
deutschland
deutschland damit möchten sie enden
herrscher habe ich im gefühl nein ich
glaube dass wir uns einfach
vergegenwärtigen müssten dass auch wir
auf diese neuen herausforderungen
reagieren müssen und dass wir uns auch
selber hinterfragen müssen und das auch
dazu führt dass wir selber den einen
oder anderen einschnitt erleben ja
und deshalb ist es durchaus lohnenswert
diese frage eines beschleunigungsgesetz
es in diesem land zu diskutieren
das ist auch sehr gut da wollen wir doch
damit weiter auch die sendung beenden
mit dem wunsch nach dem besteuerung
setze ich sage danke an meine gäste béla
anda patricia plat wolfgang bosbach
sebastian czaja und valentina maceri ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn sie nächste
woche dienstag wieder einschalten und
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend und bis bald
[Musik]